you know given your your background at
NASA this took nine years to happen why
tell us about the technology that made
this happen yeah so Pluto is really far
away and you know to have a spacecraft
that can last in deep space when I news
is really hard it's very very cold out
there and the spacecraft needed heaters
to survive and needed to travel a really
long distance to make the trip so that's
how long it takes to travel to Pluto so
Michael just how historic is this how
difficult was this to pull off an
extraordinarily difficult mission and a
beautiful mission tremendous
perseverance on the part of NASA Alan
Stern the p.i and all the hundreds of
people involved in it putting this great
technology together we've really wanted
to go take a look at what's going on out
there the outer part of the solar system
never had a clue now suddenly we're
getting this magnificent Mitch back and
I'm sure thousands more in the coming 24
36 hours so Chris how did they design
spacecraft that can withstand these
kinds of conditions yeah it's a really
tough engineering problem and so space
is very very cold when you get our
spacecraft the planet labs are in a
little bit around the earth so the earth
keeps us warm we're about room
temperature that is not true in deep
space you're basically at zero degrees
Kelvin so very very cold so New Horizons
the spacecraft going to Pluto carries a
radioisotope radio isotope thermal that
generates power and heat to keep the
spacecraft alive you're so far from the
Sun you can't use solar power for
getting energy so the spacecraft
basically has a radioisotope generator
for the temperature in power now Michael
we're already learning some new things
about Pluto and deep space but what what
are the most significant things youth
you would say that that we've learned so
far today and what could we learn still
well we can we can see that there's a
geology and that there's a lot going on
on the planet and there's weather going
on at the same time it's not the same
kind of icy watery clouds but there's
clearly methane ammonia nitrogen
substances that we don't normally think
of as being responsible for weathering
processes there's craters a lot of them
on this
surface of Pluto we can see them pretty
clearly and there are also geological
features that either could be valleys or
canyons maybe there's some sub surface
stuff going on that's carving these
features out it's clear that as we get
closer in and resolution gets much much
better even than this fabulous picture
we've already seen there's going to be a
lot more clues to try and unravel the
history of Pluto we do now know for the
first time that it is the biggest object
out there there was a toss-up between it
and Eris one other Pluto like twin Pluto
seems to have won that contest just by a
few miles but it's the biggest one out
there that is crazy to me that we didn't
know how big Pluto was until today now
we know exactly how big Pluto is but
Chris you know what else can we can we
learn here because can't we learn some
stuff about how how earth evolved yeah
that's absolutely true um so
interestingly pluto was discovered in
the mid 20th century and its orbital
period the time it takes to go around
the Sun is 248 years so since we've
discovered it has not orbited the earth
once yet and so we didn't actually know
how large it was or how far away it was
so for navigating to Pluto that was
really hard because we do you know if it
was big and close or small and far away
right so it was a huge challenge this
will tell us a lot about the formation
of the solar system how the planets are
formed what else is out there fairly
interest and there's also Michael a huge
polar ice cap on Pluto what are the
implications of that I know that that
life on Pluto is highly highly remote
the possibility of that well I I prefer
never to say never until we actually get
a probe out to Pluto land on Pluto and
drill deep underneath Pluto's surface I
don't think we're gonna know absolutely
for sure I think it's very unlikely but
the fact that there is both geology that
there are polar caps that these polar
caps melt or rather sublime that stuff
goes up into the atmosphere clouds or
some other processes we don't understand
we'll move the frozen liquids that
nitrogen the methane the ammonia from
one side to the other of the planet are
all extraordinary
narrowly interesting the only sad thing
about New Horizons is that it can't hang
around we just didn't have the energy to
send the long thrusters to slow it down
and put it into orbit around Pluto that
would have been awesome but we're going
to collect more data at New Horizons has
already collected it and will soon send
it back in the space of just a day then
we've learned in the 08 e 5 years since
Pluto was discovered and Chris one last
quick question but what kind of other
missions does this make possible public
or private or public and private yeah so
I think people went shorts blue tie was
interesting at all and it hasn't got a
lot of attention this mission was very
hard to find and I know that Alan Stern
and the other investigators tried tyros
tirelessly for decades to get this
funded now that they've gone there
they've been proven right but this place
is fascinating it is more complex than
we ever imagined and that there's a lot
of stuff out in the distant solar system
that is worth exploring so I hope to see
a whole bunch of private and public
missions going out and exploring more
deep space